es un movimiento muy pequeño pero desde
la muerte de la reina Isabel segunda ha
venido tomando más fuerza también ha
habido en estos vísperas de la
coronación una campaña liderada por esta
agrupación Republic que busca que el
Reino Unido se convierta en una
república parlamentarista para que los
británicos puedan decidir Quién es su
jefe de estado han tenido una campaña
impactante que les pregunta a las
personas
si estas personas y los británicos
votarían por Carlos para que fuera
elegido esta campaña se ha llamado
hablamos con el director de repabli
Grand Smith quien nos habla de Por qué
cree él que ahora es el momento para que
el Reino Unido en el futuro se convierta
en una república recordemos que este
país después de la guerra civil en 1600
fue una República por 11 años pero
Posteriormente se dio el proceso que se
llama la restauración entonces Carlos El
mundo tuvo que ser llamado desde los
Países Bajos para que tomara entonces
las riendas del país hablamos entonces
con gramm Smith sobre esto por qué ha
cambiado qué ha cambiado en el ambiente
aquí en el país entonces creo que la
gran diferencia es obviamente que la
Reina Isabel Ya no está allí que ella
era su jugadora estrella su escudo
térmico desvió muchas críticas y ahora
tenemos un hombre que no es
particularmente comprensivo a los ojos
de la mayoría de las personas por lo
tanto creo que sí podemos continuar
creando conciencia sobre la campaña e
involucrando a la gente veremos que las
encuestas cambiarán aún más y el apoyo a
la monarquía caerá por debajo del 50%
entonces la manifestación como cualquier
manifestación es para crear conciencias
sobre el tema y dejar muy claro frente a
las cámaras del mundo que no somos una
nación de monárquicos y de hecho somos
una nación que cada vez hace más
preguntas sobre la monarquía y queremos
ser muy fuertes y visibles para decir
que esta es una institución que debe ser
cuestionada y una institución que debe
ser abolida
Los Voceros del movimiento Republic
aseguran que con la muerte de la reina
Isabel que ha perdido la familia real a
su gran estrella y hace símbolo de
estabilidad en la historia y en la
política y en Sí en la estabilidad del
país hace que se pueda contemplar la
posibilidad de abrir ese debate sin
embargo si usted pregunta en las calles
independientemente de que sobre todo las
generaciones más jóvenes no estén tan
conectadas con la monarquía no significa
necesariamente que algo así vaya a
cambiar es un sistema político que es
tiene gran aceptación entre la mayoría
de la población Pese a que Carlos El Rey
Carlos III no es el más popular de la
familia real lo es su hijo William con
un 69% del monarca tiene el 52% Así que
es un debate que habrá que darse y hoy
también en un momento bien significativo
en la historia de este país también se
está una marcha por para exigir la
segunda un segundo referéndum de
Independencia en Escocia es un hecho
Bien bien significativo Y como lo
mencionábamos antes la próxima década a
nivel político y constitucional en este
país va a ser bien interesante también
por la posibilidad de que la isla de
Irlanda se reunifique es decir que el
norte de Irlanda Irlanda del Norte se
reunifique con la isla de Irlanda que
ves hoy la república